hello and welcome to this video playing
P Rama hey ho let's go yeah that's
interesting I recently looked at this
briefly I have to admit if he knows
things here then that's bad news because
I don't really claim detailed knowledge
it's an interesting twist to the
exchange variation let's see what he
plays now it's an important choice yeah
it's not easy to play you sexy I am okay
and I'm threatening Queen b3 now which
is quite typically ignored I thought I'm
threatening it and if I was just saying
right hmm how do I take that with the
queen with the noid with the night
maybe we should be sick stuff so let's
take it with Queen and it will be an
immediate Queen trade and you cannot
really avoid it
okay Quincy eight that is a strange move
okay yeah I'm just taking yes
in troops yeah
Jim just won a big sent upon the Slovaks
change is one of its a really underrated
line people the problem sometimes with
those lines is some similar to the
French exchange it has a really bad
reputation as being you know boring and
whatever and also some people think it
that is a bad line like the problem is
there are there is a fair amount of but
there are many players who play it with
white the Slovaks change to somehow like
play in a scared fashion for a draw
against the better player this is of
course yeah this is the plain stupid you
can just yeah you just have a very
decent solid game if you try for for
something and you can always pause
problems since it's really not that easy
to to to play for black and in the
exchange you have to know some stuff and
I mean my own experience is that with
white if you know what you're doing
you're never losing I mean you have to
do really really stupid stuff to lose
and I have one I mean tons of games and
exchanges laugh over the years my never
losing one
sometimes I even want quickly yeah
because they kind of didn't know how to
handle Queen be three lines and so on
yeah and here black resigned after 70
rules yeah the deficient g5 line is an
interesting little twist to the exchange
they normally develop the knight or play
Bishop f4 normally this is a standard
setup Bishop g5 is different obviously
as it asks black
yeah an important question how are you
going to develop your kingside without
allowing a double pawn this is actually
one of the main continuations that black
simply allow us the pawn to be doubled
just play this and after the capture
what black may also take with the pond
we have a pretty unique pawn structure
which you don't see in the exchange all
that often here I think right has
reasonable chances for a small advantage
as the black pawn structure is very
inflexible there are actually some
implications here that are not that
obvious
for example if you imagine white plays
on the Queen side very very long-term
imagine white plays normal moves like
developed slowly and then at some point
you're going for a three before night a
for the typical Queen side play and if
you do that in other lines of the
exchange now if you put lots of pieces
on the Queen side you have to reckon
with e5 quite often a counter push in
the center and this is not easy to do
for black here in this structure in
particular if you take into account then
very often black will play f5 quite
soonish because an opening of the
position with ephors often undesirable
so this is actually a quite complex
structure interesting to play and I
think white has a small pool okay we
played in this way which is possible of
course and now I have to say I'm
basically out of out of theory I know
that this is the position they often
play Knight f6 and design in this
position and transpose to the structures
that I showed but should f5 we cannot be
terrible but I'm not exactly sure about
the theoretical state this one what I
know is a success wrongly not great
I would assume point B 3 but the engine
actually thinks black can make a
sacrifice out of this which I don't
believe
Knight f6 this is the entrance line I
mean at least he's got some blacks got
some some open files and now Queen to b6
okay that is not very obvious for a
human
I cannot take f5 because of this I mean
okay engine says equal but you still
don't want that but if I go here is that
full compensation it's tough to believe
and it's got a bit of compensation III
is weak but there you it doesn't win it
huh yeah I mean that is not a position
that you go for voluntarily as black
after cream b725 I think it's it's just
a one it's nothing you're just suffering
I think 95 is a bit better in comparison
than 93 of it I would have played 92
just I don't want any structural
concession if you keep the pawn
structure intact here you should fairly
easily go into conversion of the extra
pawn yeah this is losing even more time
95 now and okay f6s not a happy move you
know to my bishop g6 and 95 it's just
curtains yeah black resigned he have no
nothing developed and you're losing even
more material yeah the exchange Slav a
small a bad line I don't think there's
anything wrong with it
in terms of trying to play for an
advantage you always have to keep in
mind that the white doesn't have much
direction the Slav anyway yet if you
play a complex mainline black it's all
security equalized okay guys thanks for
watching